you transform yourself for every film
you do you're a great actor but you also
change your body when you did southpaw
we have a picture of you from that movie
you got in sick shape insane shape
unless that's a prosthetic chest in
which case I want to know where I can
purchase one yeah now that's not my body
but thank you I really know I yeah I
mean I learned at a box for the for the
movie that's what happens when you learn
how to box you get in really good shape
you get in in crazy shape yes when you
were in that shape do you think okay
let's say you were in that shape right
now Ronda Rousey is our second guest how
long do you think you'd last in the ring
with Ronda Rousey Jake Gyllenhaal in
that shape versus Ronda Rousey go like
that's it it's done it's over I'm an
actor let's be honest Yeah right but I
know I mean I've learned long ago I have
a very strong mother and a very strong
sister and I was raised by both of them
a wonderful dad I might add yes but I I
know not to put themselves
you